y nos vamos ya a directo aquí en directo
América edición nocturna hoy nos vamos
concretamente hasta México con nuestro
corresponsal Mario carbonell porque el
presidente del país Andrés Manuel López
Obrador anunció que rechaza pasar el
mando de la alianza del Pacífico a Perú
sin embargo aseguró que no es una
negación rotunda sino que consultará a
los miembros del grupo de ríos sobre qué
paso dar y entonces aceptará su decisión
Mario Cuáles han sido las razones detrás
de este anuncio de Lopez Obrador y qué
repercusiones ha tenido en la política
colombiana
Hola Pues el presidente argumenta que
considera al gobierno actual de Perú
como espurio dice que entregarle la
presidencia de la alianza sería
legitimar un golpe de estado que él
asegura es contrario a las libertades a
los derechos humanos y es
antidemocrático es Por ello que dijo no
está dispuesto o no quiere por lo menos
ahora entregar la presidencia
hay alguna reacciones ya en el sector
político en México sobre todo el partido
Acción Nacional de oposición ha fijado
una postura para criticar este esta este
posicionamiento de López Obrador y
señalar que está marcado por su
ideología en temas de política exterior
dice que busca apoyar a sus amigos
autoritarios de la región En referencia
a Pedro castillo y también considera que
no puede López Obrador tomar una
decisión de esta naturaleza de manera
unilateral esta postura se suma a la que
ya se había dado en días previos por
parte de senadores del mismo partido
Acción Nacional pero también de otros
partidos del Pri incluso del grupo
plural como Emilio Álvarez icaza Beatriz
paredes Gina Cruz que han cuestionado
que López Obrador Por una parte busque
intervenir en Perú Pero por otra parte
calle no diga nada de la situación de
Derechos Humanos que está viviendo Por
ejemplo Nicaragua Así un poco las
reacciones hasta ahora en torno de esta
decisión de López Obrador consultada por
Franz 24 la internacionalista Erika Ruiz
considera que no es viable que los
países que integran lo que fuera el
grupo de Río tomen una postura ahora a
ese respecto
bueno Mario Desde la detención de Pedro
Castillo Perú acusó a México de
injerencia en los asuntos internos En
qué punto En qué en qué punto se
encuentran ahora las relaciones entre
ambos países
sin duda están en una muy mala situación
hay que recordar que desde el 21 de
diciembre el gobierno de Dina boluarte
expulsó a quien fuera embajador mexicano
en ese país Pablo Monroy le dio 72 horas
para que abandonara esa nación esto a
raíz de el asilo que dio el gobierno
mexicano a la familia de Castillo desde
entonces ha sido una relación fría al
grado de Que hoy ya abiertamente el
presidente mexicano considera espurio al
gobierno de Dina boluarte y pues esto ha
generado reacciones no solamente en
México sino también en Perú por parte de
congresistas de aquella nación que
critican esta intervencionismo de López
Obrador en cuestiones domésticas del
Perú